I've had in today's page for this
today's whiteboard because that way when
you go to the textbook you'll know what
this is talking about okay this is this
is actually the heading of the exercise
eh okay but it's not that big a deal
like all the stuff you must demonstrate
over here or help you with this okay so
here's a simple problem I'm going to
show you two ways to do this probably
and I'll let you decide which way you
feel you're most comfortable with
okay so long as you can do either of you
two inches on one unit so option one is
called comment another
do you remember you remember women this
question number four right I suggested
to you fractions accurst running few
with the fraction let's just take the
fraction out of things like completely
and then macho good the question is
necessary okay so I've got two fractions
here I want to get rid of both of them
okay now being that fractions about
division the way to get rid of fractions
which is division is to what's the
opposite division multiplied right so I
want to choose a number then I can
multiply both sides by that'll clear out
all the fractions okay
now that was really easy here because it
is only one fraction so that's why we
multiply by to make sense but hey if I
multiply by three or five
you'll only get rid of one of them and I
kind of want to get rid of everything so
in other words why what is the common
denominator what is the common
denominator to be three funny it's 15
like if I multiply both sides by 15 it
will clear off both fraction so it's
dinner I'm gonna write out this step so
multiplied by science simple thing and
because of us choosing the common
denominator this is going to come out
and wash I can cancel
in both cases right so for example
left-hand side what kind of cancel guy
that one would go what do I get left
with I had this good and then over here
I could cancel the 5 what do I get left
me very good so now I multiply through
and once I drew that because I chose my
numbers well I got fired and X and then
I've got three to two [ __ ] things
okay so now we've taken this awkward
thing with fractions everywhere which we
hate it and this is pretty simple isn't
it what do I do to both sides
the final okay
does games right now that is simple I
want you to notice though this
do you remember when multiply both sides
by 15 and then we disappear that's all
Mike Ross tells oh okay now would you
pay really close attention to the
numbers that appear after we did all the
canceling five and three five and three
those numbers look really suspicious
they look like they kind of came from
somewhere where would five and three in
our original question
yeah there were no these denominators
right except you might see they've kind
of um they're kind of swap sides the
reason that scientists could be
multiplied across now therefore like
instead of Oh about 15 that's a big
number and you'll get bigger as we have
a look at more different questions
I've got option two which is to go
straight to this five in this three with
less steps right so this option to some
of you have met this before is called
cross multiplying okay so here's the
idea I'm gonna even draw it up on the
board see if you can see here right I
multiplied by 15 to get rid of both of
them okay but is that what I can do is
if I multiply both sides by five this
five is going to miss it a language we
were using before right this time is
going to come up the top here do you see
that multiply both by five and ends up
on this numerator disappears from here
and appears up and then at the same time
if I multiply by this three now he just
migrates over there can you see why it's
called cross multiplication okay
not very mention you right so once I've
done that I literally say well that's
gonna be five times X I just go straight
to that line right that denominator
comes up here
I do the same thing on the other side
multiply that 2 by 3 thank you
six and you can see i got to where i was
gonna get before except I just didn't
have to quite as much or substantially
faster
okay so I still end up with the same so
you've got these three techniques up
your sleeve cross multiplying and
commenting on it now they're kind of two
ways to do the same thing but because
this is faster a lot more happening in
your brain that might be a bit much for
you if you do this method and yeah I'm
just running into mistakes that's okay
just come back to this and then migrate
over when you feel confident okay but
this is up this is quicker and I
encourage you enjoy if you like yeah
yeah you know what you know what I'd
literally I if you really want to
indicate what you're doing you can put
these like the actual errors in that's
the cross modification action but
honestly there is not and this is the
great thing about it
there's no intervening life you can get
straight to that that is the cross
multiplication I suppose you can really
want it to you could say it's 5 times X
and 2 times 3 so that the multiplication
is really obvious but I think we can do
all of that now so you've done a the
long way around so I think the key is
and you can see that when I draw the
errors right like we don't have to
double up the work x 15 can sing on both
side is doing work and then undoing it
whereas here it's like it just goes
straight there and straight there yeah
so the arrows is what helped me it gives
me that